Walter Isaacson thank you for joining us
we're here to talk about your new book
Elon Musk the lot has already been
written about Elon Musk he lives his
life between the tweets upended
reinvented the Auto industry Aerospace
now trying it with Twitter turned X you
spent two years shadowing him what did
you learn that we didn't already know
about Elon Musk well there's certainly
multiple Elon musk's multiple
personalities whether it's the hardcore
engineering mode that you know so well
where you can figure out how to do a
battery cell or more importantly figure
out how to do steps on an assembly line
that will make the Battery South but
also there's almost a demon mode of Elon
Musk where he turns really dark and that
can be very problematic especially when
it came to acquiring Twitter which I
think involves more emotional
intelligence the other thing I learned
about musk is where those demons come
from and they come from a childhood that
was rather brutal a father that was
psychologically abusive
all of us have demons probably from
childhood mine are probably a bit milder
than others and his a lot worse than
others but with a mosque or anybody you
figure out how did they Channel those
demons and turn them into drives I want
to get to demon Mona just a second and
talk about his father but let's set the
maybe set the table here he let you go
everywhere how you know where the ground
rules anything off limits did you sleep
on the factory floor next to him you
know I slept in Airstream trailers down
in the South Tip of Texas where SpaceX
has its launch pad I spent a lot of late
nights in factories he put nothing off
limits which surprised the heck out of
me I mean meetings that were about
forward-looking products everything else
he said I just want to surprise you
about the transparency in my side of the
deal was fine I want to be everywhere
but you get no control over the book you
don't even get to read it before it
comes out has he read it now I don't
know he says on Twitter I don't know he
says he hasn't so we'll see you've
written a lot of books Steve Jobs
biography was maybe perhaps an instant
classic and in that book you talk about
the challenge of breaking through the
Apple co-founders reality Distortion
field with musk you had extraordinary
access by my account you talked to more
than 120 people around him close
deputies even family members his father
even
did you worry about that reality
Distortion field that he has the fact
that he can sometimes be an unreliable
narrator in his own life well yes he can
be unreliable and his memory is fallible
and he sort of cloaks himself as a hero
in every tale but I didn't feel a
reality Distortion field he was not he
almost was unaware of my presence it
seemed a lot of times because he'd be
being a real jerk to people at a meeting
or blow up on a walk around one of the
rocket sites and I'd think wait a minute
doesn't he know I'm taking notes here so
it did surprise me how open and in some
ways not trying to sugarcoat things he
was in some ways you became part of the
Inner Circle right you follow him around
for so long how did you balance that
kind of push to have him talk to you but
also him asking you how he should do
things that as an impartial Observer
that must have been a challenge well I
tried very hard to be impartial and no I
wasn't trying to give him advice at one
point like he mentioned he said
something about some blue check box and
I asked him a question why the hell are
you even labeling it this way you know
what's the point of it and then later he
said oh yeah Walter Isaacson told me not
I just like no no that was just a
question so I tried pretty hard to just
make it questions the controversy was
over labeling the BBC and NPR as state
affiliate media and he said that he got
the idea to get rid of that labeling
because of you do you I think maybe
though it speaks to where he's getting
inputs for the way he's making decisions
he's getting it Beyond just his senior
leadership team he's kind of canvassing
the world sometimes yeah he processes
information from all over the place
canvases the world on Twitter puts up
polls and things and sometimes you have
no idea that he's getting feedback he's
not very good at getting pushed back
from people around him he can bristle
but he batch processes it which means it
takes a while you watch him process
something and then he'll switch course
on a lot of things you spent
part of the book in the beginning
talking about his childhood and his
relationship with his father what was
what was the early days of Elon Musk
like you know he's a scrawny kid
socially awkward beaten up on the
playground a whole lot went to a
Wilderness Camp in which you know sort
of survival and he lost 10 pounds in a
week because they kept beating him up
and taking his food but when he went
back to the Wilderness Camp a few years
later he had gotten bigger he learned a
little Judo and he said I just learned
to punch people in the nose as hard as I
could when they were being mean to me
and sometimes they'd beat me up but if I
punch them really hard in the nose they
wouldn't do it again you almost see that
nowadays which is these pugnacious he
sometimes can be so confrontational and
when in doubt he punches in the nose you
talk about his relationship with his
father his father is almost described
like a Jekyll and hyde-like character
sometimes he can be friendly sometimes
he can be volatile Ashley Vance and his
biography of Elon Musk kind of explored
a little bit of this and musk has kind
of alluded to some of this in the past
but I I've never seen him go so in depth
about that childhood experience why do
you think he was ready to talk about it
now it took a long time for us to want
to talk about his childhood I just sat
there I'd raise it every now and then
and sometimes we'd get to a place where
suddenly he'd start talking about his
father and he would go and get
teary-eyed at times very very emotional
and just say you don't know how bad the
abuse was and I talked of course to
Kimball musk his brother about it and
may musk his mother but then I talked to
Arrow musk the father I wanted to hear
all sides of this and after a while Elon
just kept opening up about the
psychological scars he had when his
father would make him stand in front of
his father and yell at him for more than
an hour and take the sides of the people
who had beaten up Elon and call Elon
stupid you write that the PTSD from his
childhood also instilled in him an
aversion to contentment you quote times
who's the mother of three of his
children and one of his former wives
about this kind of issue that he has
what do you think
that means for the companies that he
runs what does that mean for the the
people that work for him as they try to
reach the goals and sometimes achieve
those goals he's addicted to drama he's
addicted to risk and whenever things
seem to be going smoothly he almost has
a compulsion to stir things up I've
watched it happen a dozen times whether
it's on standing on a roof late at night
where he's there installing the Tesla
solo roof and he just says okay we're
going to have to have a surge and he
disrupts the whole thing he disrupted
full-service driving a few months ago
and I was there which is no we're going
to make it based on artificial
intelligence and machine learning not on
coding so it allows him to become a
disruptive figure but also a difficult
leader one of the things that I think is
really unique about this book is your
fly on the wall seeing this you know I
have written others have written a lot
about the Mercurial way or the way he
treats his employees but it's always
from the perspective of after the fact
you were there in the room
um what do you think was one of the most
surprising kind of instances of him
losing his temper with one of his
employees oh one night in South Texas at
the launch pad of SpaceX it's a Friday
night at 10 pm and everything's going
smoothly there's no launches being
scheduled and he looks and there's only
two people working at the launch pad and
all of a sudden I see demon mode coming
in almost like storm clouds from the
Gulf of Mexico and I'm thinking well
it's Friday night at 10 pm and yet he
just Reams out this guy named Andy who
was in charge of the launch pad site and
he orders a search he orders a hundred
people to come in from different parts
of SpaceX from Florida California so
they can all work for 24 hours a day
getting this thing done even though
there was no need to afterwards I went
back to Andy and said what was it like
to be in the line of fire because I not
only wanted elon's side I wanted to see
what it does to people like you know a
person who has been caught in that demon
mode it's one of these interesting kind
of paradoxes you see with elon's
companies in one hand he inspires on the
other hand he kind of runs through a lot
of people rather quickly given all of
the stories about how he treats people
why do you think he still has the
ability to attract talent to his
companies well as you know Glenn
Shotwell at SpaceX has been there more
than 20 years as the president at Tesla
people like Fritz von Holzhausen Lars
moravi others have been there for a long
time and those are the ones who so buy
into the mission that they're willing to
take some of the burnout I talked to
some of the people on the autopilot team
at Tesla when they were doing Optimus
the robot and a couple of them had quit
because it was just too brutal dealing
with them and they got burned out but
then one of them was back because of
what happened he said I decided I had a
choice between being burned out or being
bored and I decided I wanted to be
burned out because I believed in the
mission so some survive but a whole lot
don't let's go back to this idea of
demon mode what is demon mode in your
mind demon mode is something that
happened to his father as well it's
almost like Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde where
a cloud comes over and he gets into a
trance and he can just be tough in a
cold way he never gets really angry
never gets that physical but coldly
brutal to people and he almost doesn't
remember afterwards what he's done
sometimes they'll say why did you say
that to that person and he'll look at me
blankly as if he didn't quite remember
what happened while he was in Demon mode
and sometimes I've talked to people
who've worked with him for years and
years who consider themselves close with
him and they've seen it occur to them he
just goes into another world and doesn't
seem to remember it after the fact
exactly it's almost you see a storm
cloud coming in and he's in a trance
and his father says it happens to me
meaning the father he says and I can't
help it it just happens and likewise it
happens to Elon that's not to excuse it
but he hardly remembers that he's done
it
now one of the things that Claire
Boucher on his Grime says is you don't
want to be around him when he's in Demon
mode it's really frightening he said she
said but she eventually added but demon
mode is what gets done you were
around it did you get to did you get a
sense of when it was going to come I
remember once late at night and Grimes
was there she leaned over to me and said
demon mode and I didn't see it yet it
was but she knew it was about to happen
like somebody can feel the change in
pressure and boom about a minute later
he got really dark so it's like being
somebody with somebody who has multiple
personalities at times sometimes he'll
be Giddy and funny and pulling out his
phone and making you watch a Monique
python clip about silly walks while he's
doing Optimus the robot but then he can
switch quickly to being engineering mode
or sometimes being inspirational and
sometimes being very dark is demon mode
Elon musk's superpower is it equivalent
to Steve Jobs reality Distortion field
is is demon mode the way that allows
Elon to kind of plow through when
something's needed to be plowed through
that's sort of the theme of the book is
can you take out the dark threads and
still have the whole Fabric and it's
true of Steve Jobs which is he had a
reality Distortion field and without
that he wouldn't have driven people
crazy but it wouldn't have driven people
to do things they didn't think they
could do likewise there are times where
this risk-taking dark I'm going to push
ahead no matter what personality is what
it takes to I mean he's the only guy
getting astronauts into orbit from the
U.S only guy who can send up that many
satellites who can land a booster who
can bring us into the air of electric
vehicles that doesn't excuse demon mode
but in the book I try to show how that's
one of the strong and a fabric and as
Shakespeare said you know we're molded
out of our faults if we pull that strand
out you might not get the whole cloth of
Elon Musk is demon mode a lack of
empathy or is it something else demon
mode certainly has a lack of empathy and
there are times when musk very much has
a lack of empathy
he says sometimes not having too much
empathy can be beneficial because he'll
talk about John McNeil who had been
president of Tesla and John McNeil
always wanted the people in front of
them to like him he was always very kind
which meant that he didn't fire people
he wasn't Tough Enough on them so
sometimes Steve Jobs said this to me as
well if you're somebody's gonna wear
velvet gloves and not tell people
something they're doing is wrong and not
say it tough enough you'll never get
things going I think about Michael
Lewis's liars poker and kind of the
unintended consequences of that book
that kind of inspired a generation to go
to Wall Street when he thought it was
perhaps kind of a cautionary Tale do you
think some of the details about Elon
musk's life that
demon mode might inspire a generation of
wannabe entrepreneur entrepreneurs I
want to be business Executives to be an
or or are we inspiring a
generation of in behavior that
really is probably a nightmare for a lot
of HR departments are there lessons here
though that you know you think the
future can take from the way Elon Musk
operates well certainly don't try this
you shouldn't try to be like Elon Musk
biographies are not how-to books uh with
Steve Jobs people would come up to me
after they read the book and said I'm
just like Steve Jobs when somebody does
something bad I tell them it sucks I go
wait a minute have you invented the
iPhone have you invented the Macintosh
we don't have either the right to be
that way nor should they be that way so
I hope people come from the books on
anybody and say all right I'm going to
try to learn the lessons of what makes
somebody effective but I'm also going to
learn the cautionary tales you don't
have to be this mean I guess you bring
up Steve Jobs and musk uh did you see
any similarities between the two oh yeah
both of them have a deeply Innovative
sense that comes from as Steve Jobs
would say being able to think different
they're willing to be disruptors uh and
you know jobs is famous uh ad uh in
which he says here's to the Misfits the
rebels around pets in the square hole
and end by saying and the people are
crazy enough to think they can change
the world are the ones who do well Elon
Musk is crazy half the time he thinks he
can change the world what's the biggest
difference between the two I think they
each deserve separate biographies and
they each deserve uh to be celebrated
for what they did well who would rather
have a beer with
uh
uh and which of my children do I like
the most or whatever I think I'm not
going to go there
we'll talk about this it seems like
Steve Jobs could be legendarily hard on
people but it seemed as if towards the
end of his career he at least put
together an executive team that he he
trusted he would be hard on them but
they could change his mind they might
not be easy to change his mind but he
could do that with Elon Musk it seems
very hard to change his mind you have
some examples of people being successful
at it but do you do you think Elon is
harder on his trusted team than Steve
Jobs was I think one of the failings
musk has is he doesn't take negative
feedback uh very well and he doesn't
necessarily allow people to tell him no
on the other hand after a while the
people who have worked with him a long
time know how to turn him around and
eventually he processes the information
and does it for example he always was
against building the cheap Global car
the twenty five thousand dollar car he
wanted to do a robo taxi but he wanted
to have no steering wheel and the kept
saying no no no we have to do one for
now that'll be good about four or five
months ago there's a meeting and once
again they present them with this you
got to have the Next Generation twenty
five thousand dollar car You Gotta Have
It have a steering wheel he says okay
let's do it I mean you're hitting on
this thing at one of the the axioms of
kind of the way he operates is that it's
okay to be wrong uh just as long as
you're not confident and wrong but one
of the challenges is the way he treats
people sometimes people are afraid to
tell him the bad news I think that's one
of his problems is people sometimes are
afraid to tell him the bad news and then
he keeps pushing at them and saying get
the bad news out there often get it out
there first and people like Martin Cosa
one of the sidekicks he has at SpaceX
who's been with him a long time whenever
you're at a meeting with him he's
forcing the people at the meeting to
give the bad news first and so those who
succeed around musk are those who figure
out you got to give them the bad news
even if it's gonna result in some
unpleasant scenes another key one of the
ways of how he tries to manage or how he
kind of tries to think about the world
is something he calls first principles
which is essentially a problem-solving
way to not take what's been done in the
past is the way it should be done in the
future is trying to reach the ultimate
goal of whatever you're setting out kind
of getting to the root problem and
figuring out from there but that's very
abstract it's kind of hard to put that
understand what he means by that but it
seems as if by sitting around with him
you've kind of seen the way he's trying
to impart that decision-making framework
to people with something called the
algorithm what is the algorithm the
algorithm is a five-step process for not
only making good products and designing
good products but manufacturing them and
you're right it begins with first
principles he says question every
requirement and by first principles he
means look down at the physics if
somebody says no we can't build it at
this Price He says tell me how much the
materials cost lost tell me exactly
what's involved here and then tell me
you can or can't do it when he first was
trying to buy a rocket booster in Russia
early on and they were charging him 15
million dollars or something on the
flight home he calculated how much is
the cost of materials and Fuel and he
said okay those are the first principles
so we should be able to make it at a
much cheaper cost with the algorithm
he's always saying question every
requirement and then delete delete
delete so he simplifies things and then
only then do you start to speed up the
manufacturing process and eventually
automate it one of his big mistakes at
Tesla was he went to automation too
quickly before he had deleted every part
and questioned every requirement you're
a fly on the wall through a lot of
things including the kind of the issues
that arose out of starlink's involvement
with you Ukraine and Russia you know
there's some details in there about how
he limited the ability of starlink to
operate in parts of the world that
affected the Ukraine and their plans for
the war and this has sparked real
questions about the power that he holds
in geopolitical settings the power of
War do you think he has really processed
that power that he has that I watched
him process the power he has say over
Ukraine and the first thing you have to
realize is he's the only person who's
been able to put up communication
satellites that were able to withstand
rushing hacking and so he supplies them
to Ukraine in order to save their war
effort but after a while he's geofenced
off part of Crimea it causes one of
their attacks to fail and he realizes
hey why am I in this movie I made this
thing so that people could watch movies
and play video games and he eventually
calls uh Jake Sullivan the National
Security advisor Mark milley the chair
of the joint change of staff and they
work out a deal where starlink sells a
certain number of these satellites to
the U.S military and the U.S government
gets to decide how they're used so you
watch him process the idea that maybe
he's got to give up some of this power I
mean it's one thing for him to kind of
be I don't know wishy-washy or Mercurial
when he's running Tesla and changing
things or SpaceX and changing things
those are his businesses but when it
comes to influencing War
um that's taking it to a new level and
it makes you kind of Wonder is he King
Solomon in these his decisions or is he
kind of a new kind of a dictator that is
more powerful than a government I think
he's very Mercurial and he makes
intuitive impulsive decisions and I
think as in the case with starlink he'll
create something called star Shield
which is a military version of it and
say and I'm going to give up control of
this I'm going to sell it to certain
governments and they have control over
it so he's somewhat self-aware but he
does have an epic you know hero complex
of which he's some comic book character
wearing his underpants on the outside
trying to save the world and that can be
worrisome at times I mean one of the
things about him is that he has acquired
a lot of power right he's the world's
richest man he is changing Industries
and you see over time that some people
rise into power and maybe they want to
use it with velvet gloves or in the
background they don't necessarily want
to you know have their Footprints over
things where he has no objection to
everyone knowing that he's he's doing
what he's doing do you think there's
something different about that does it
get back to that original idea of
punching somebody in the nose so they
know that he's willing to punch them I
think it gets back to a kid scrawny kid
getting beaten up on the playground and
then hiding in the corner of a bookstore
reading the comic books of the
superheroes and he really did develop a
sense of mission a mission that we
should become space-faring and go to
Mars a mission that we should move to
the era of electric vehicles that we
have to tame Robotics and artificial
intelligence and I think he sees himself
as truly driven by these epic missions
you know you talk about mission and some
of his key supporters have been
frustrated with him because they bought
into the mission of Tesla they bought in
the mission of SpaceX but then they see
him with Twitter now known as X and they
wonder why he's putting his time there
what was your take away was it because
he wants to own the playground as you
kind of suggested or was it just impulse
it was impulse to buy Twitter
it's because he wants to own the world's
great playground
it's also because 20 years earlier he
had created a company called x.com which
became PayPal and he wanted it to become
both the financial system connected to a
social network and everything happened
he sees Twitter turned into X being
something that can fulfill that Vision
I'd have to imagine that when you
started out to write this book you what
did you think the ending was going to be
because I can't imagine you imagined
Twitter X was going to be the kind of
the ending part of it no I started the
book I thought okay man this is somebody
who's shooting up rockets and he can
make them land and get things to know
but nobody else can do it he's also
learned how to do manufacturing which
nobody's been able to do recently he's
also brought us into batteries and
electric vehicles that can sell a
million a year and I thought this is
going to be a fun while looking book
about some great technology but yeah
then Twitter comes along and for that
matter artificial intelligence where he
summons me last March back to Austin and
says I'm going to start a company to do
AI so this is a guy who can't leave well
enough alone do you see him moving into
a new era where he's essentially seeding
a bunch of ideas almost a Thomas Edison
character putting money towards bigger
ideas and letting smart people invent it
or is he going to kind of keep control
like a Henry Ford back in the day of of
making sure the Model T was the Model T
for as long as possible well I think one
of his uh weaknesses I'll call it is he
really is a control freak you want him
to give up control say of Twitter you're
thinking okay Linda yakarino should run
it but he doesn't really see too much
control Glenn Shotwell at SpaceX learns
how to deal with him he really is
focused on the products he gets to run
the company but no I don't see him
giving up a lot of control over these
companies even though they're now six or
seven of them depending on how you count
that he's running are we in the Final
Act of this kind of narrative or has he
peaked is he on the decline
um I would say that for many years
people have predicted his kind of the
Epic collapse of something and he's been
able to get through it is is this just
another example of that you know
throughout my book we've got the Epic
collapse is about to happen we have as
you know well 2018 when Tesla and SpaceX
are both having problems go back to 2008
they both run out of money at the end of
that year people say it's all over
likewise after he gets Twitter he starts
ripping out the servers and fires 85
percent of the team I keep waking up in
the morning thinking this thing won't
appear on my phone anymore it's going to
be gone and taking on AI it seems like
he's doing it late after open Ai and
Google have done it but at the moment
nothing's collapsed some of them are
going to collapse this can be like it's
rocket chips and everything else he
believes you can't get into orbit
without blowing things up every now and
then so there will be debris there will
be things blown up but I think you know
most things he's done keeps surprising
me as being successful okay he's been a
success in these these places let's go
back to the beginning of the book though
the kind of the influence of his father
and these demons that he was fighting
and the concern that his mother even
Ventures out that he could become like
his father in the end is has he become
his father it's an epic struggle almost
like Star Wars where you know the Luke
Skywalkers got to fight the dark side of
the force and becoming Darth Vader
becoming his father and that's what Mae
must said the danger for Elon is that he
becomes his father and you see signs of
that even in the demon mode the dark
mode he gets into you see signs of it
and some of the tweets and the political
move to the right but you also see the
struggle to harness the demons and you
see an understanding of what his
childhood instilled in him and how he's
got to fight those demons you say in the
book that John McNeil tells you John
McNeil had been one of the key deputies
at Tesla at a certain point he asked
Elon if he was bipolar and Elon suggests
that maybe that was the case
Elon and Saturday Night Live a few years
ago talks about how he has Asperger's
I'm actually making history tonight as
the first person with Asperger's to host
SNL though his mother says he was never
tested as a kid
or at least the first to admit it
he talked to you about Asperger's do you
think he actually has it I mean it's an
idea that's been out there for a long
time but
um is a diagnosed is is it part of kind
of who he is and why he's successful is
it part of why he struggles well in the
book you'll hear him talking about his
psychological struggles you hear him
talking about his depression uh yeah he
says I've never been diagnosed as
bipolar but that might be the case uh as
with Asperger's there's so many
different forms of autism spectrum
disorder but there's some elements in
his case well you see he doesn't have
that empathy that his brother Kimball
has so all of that is part of this
makeup of this complex character
most of the time is channeled into being
able to accomplish some pretty
astonishing things but a lot of the
times it makes your head snap in closing
here Does Elon Musk go to Mars and die
there like he's talked about well he
says I certainly want to go to Mars and
die there but not on impact no I don't
think he personally will make it to Mars
even though he's kind of hoping so I
think by the end of his life he will
have gotten missions to Mars but he's
not like some of these other
billionaires he's not eager to be the
first on the rocket